メンバーシップの新着記事が届きました
ゆな先生
2026年9月21日 09:57
noteで読む
著名キャバクラJUNGLE TOKYOのトップキャバクラ嬢のヤマトリノとその彼氏がコカイン所持で逮捕されたというニュースが流れたのは2026年9月16日のことであった。
ネット上では彼氏がいたことに腹を立てた知人がキャバ嬢を売ったのだとか、キャバ嬢は売春婦だとか、いろんな議論が走っているが、遠い世界の話のように聞こえてくる。
いっぽうで、半グレや反社、トクリュウや裏社会や水商売というのは、私たちが普段遠い世界にいると思いながらも、実は普段の日常のすぐそばにいる。
いぜんゆな先生がトクリュウの高額バイト案件の応募に申し込みを進めていくとどうなるのかという記事を公開したが、私たちの使うXやLINEで簡単に彼らと接点を持つことが出来ることを解説した。
ゆな先生の記事で2,3番目の人気の記事であった(1位は
ドバイ戦争脱出編
さて、今から遡ることコロナ前の話であるが、ゆな先生がうっかり半グレマンションに入ってしまった話をする。
当然のようにある薬物、セックス、詐欺、犯罪。
何がその場で起きていたかを解説する。
なお、今回は身の安全を守るため、多少記載を事実と変更して記載をするが、内容に脚色はなく、今回の執筆文章には当然一切の生成エーアイを使っていない。
「半グレマンション」とはどういうものだったのか、そこでの薬物とセックス、その日の思い出を思い出していこうと思う。
ホームパーティ
2010年代の末であるが、ゆな先生は「ホームパーティ」なるものに参加していた。
ホームパーティとは、家でおにぎりとかお寿司とかを食べて家族で楽しく、というものではなく、港区でたわまんとか高級マンションとか、会員制ラウンジとかを貸し切ってやるような、出会いの場のようなものである。
ゆな先生は反社とかパパ活とかは好まないので、基本的には人と出会ったり、楽しく話せる場所として、(そして恋愛対象の相手が見つかるといいなとか思って)月に1,2回参加していた。
このような「ホームパーティ」には大まかに分けると2種類あり、金だけはあるおっさんが開催しているものと、若いエリサラやボンボン息子がやっている2つがある。
前者は怪しさは非常に大きく、おじさん男性が多くいて、ギャラ飲みとしてお金を貰って会場に来て座っている港区女子がいたりする。
オッサンたちは当然女性を持ち帰ってセックスすることを目的にしている。
会場は会員制のバーのときも多いが、高級マンションの一室だったりもする。
何億もするようなマンションである。
出てくる酒も高い。
後者は単純にイキったエリサラとか金持ち息子がやっているもので、意外と20代前半とか中盤の人間が主催していることもある。
出てくる酒は安い。
大体は出会いを求めてたりとか、単純にやりたいだけというのもあるが、大学を卒業して仕事ばかりをやっているのもつまらないし、普通にモテるタイプの人間も多い。
男女ともに出会いを求めて、ギャラ飲みではなく人のつてで集まってくるものが多い。
「友達呼んできて今度」みたいな感じで人が集まる。
ゆな先生は前者は気持ち悪いし、新しい出会いがあるといいなと思っていたので後者に行くことが多かった。
親が相続税の節税目的とかのために買ったり、東京にいく大学生の息子とか東京で就職した息子のために買った何億円もするようなマンションなどになんども行った。
基本的に、おじさんたちが主催するマンションの場合は、ギャラ飲みで来ている女子も多いし、帰る時にタクシー代を貰うことすらもできる。
多くの港区女子はタクシー代を貰うときに
「大宮に住んでいて」
とか言って2万くらいせびることもある。
港区女子は大体ワンメーターで降りて、港区に住むIT社長とかセフレの家に泊まって、タクシー代を貰っておきながら自分の懐に入れる。
貴重な収入源である。
翌日の朝の始発で家に帰る。
都心に住んでいることもあるが、遠いとさいたまとか茨城から通っていたりするので、土曜朝の港区の始発時間の電車には、派手な格好のパリピ女子が乗っていたりするし、六本木の朝などにふらふら歩いていたりする。
若いエリートサラリーマンたちが主催するマンションでは、基本的には女性はあまりお金を払うことはないが、対等な業界飲みとか、同年代飲みみたいな場合は、女性が1000円とか2000円程度払わされることもある。
タク代などは当然だが出ないが、年齢が近いし純粋な出会いがある。
男性たちは大体は金曜の夜に仕事を終えて段々と増えてきて、家からワインとかを持ってきて参加をするのが定番であった。
女性側は社会人だけではなく、大学生を呼ぶことも結構あり、立教大学とか上智大学とか女子大なども多かったが、果ては中央大学のような多摩のド田舎にあるような大学の女子大生まで来ていることもあった。
大学生が大学生を呼ぶし、エリサラたちも大学生とやりたいので呼ぶ。
大学生もきらびやかな世界に足を踏み入れたと勘違いして、ヤリ捨てされたり、みんなの穴として活躍していく。
ブスなやつは仲間を呼ぶ能力があると判断されればなんども呼ばれて仲間を供給するハブとして使われていく。
中にはまともに交際するカップルなどができる場合もある。
その日にお持ち帰りされるとかもよくあるが、私が見た中で最速だったのは来て20分で女子大生をお持ち帰りした外資コンサルの男であった。
MBBのどれかで働いているだけあって、優秀である。
もちろん、こうした会の中には慶應とか東大の女子学生、もしくは慶應とか東大を出たエリートな外資系社員の女子なども来ているが、その女子たちは同じような仕事をしている男性と単純に知り合いたいとか、話す相手を求めてきていたりとか、出会いを求めてきたりというのがあって、お持ち帰りされるケースというのは比較的少なかった。
六本木のたわまん
さて、そうやって夜な夜な週末になると人との出会いを求めたり、楽しい夜を求めてパーティ会場に行き、その後どこかのクラブに行ったりとかしていたわけだが、ある日、会場がまさにヤマトリノさんが住んでいると言われている
[EN]THE ROPPONGI TOKYO[/EN]
であった。
私がヤマトリノさんの逮捕の映像で映っていたマンションの建物から、これが
THE ROPPONGI TOKYOであると判定ができたのは、私が行ったことがあったから
である。
そしてこの高級マンション自体が、入り口やロビー、廊下などですれ違う人からして、
明らかに夜の街の人たち、もしくは何で稼いでるか分からない人たちが多かった
からとても強く印象が残っていたし、港区界隈では明らかに異質なマンションであるから、おそらく界隈の人なら
「あ、あのマンションに住んでるのね…」
と察するものがあると思う。
さて、その夜のことであるが、若い人たちが主催をするたわまんのパーティ自体は同じであり、よく港区のパーティで出会うような人たちと、もしくは私の知り合いもその場にいて、普段と違う嘘のない楽しいパーティであった。
ただ泡を飲み、恋愛の話をし、仕事の話をしたり、ワイワイとするだけであった。
ただ、その会だけ少し違ったのは、ややちょっと見た目が半グレに近いような、ちょっと怖い見た目をした人たちが何名か混ざっており、どうやらその家の所有者とその仲間が、その半グレ系の人たちのようであった。
大体泡で乾杯して、その後ワイン飲んだり、ちょっとしたオードブルみたいなものを食べたりするのは普段と同じであったが、来る女性たちはどちらかというと、派手な水商売をしていそうな、港区界隈によくいる自称モデルのような、何をして稼いでいるか分からない女性たちが結構来ていた。
この女性たちは大学を出ているかもわからないし、出ているとしてもFランの女子大卒とか学生であり、普段自分が関わることもないのだが、この港区では大きな顔をして歩いている。
よくわからない自称モデルのような女性たちには天敵がいて、東大とか慶應出身のバリバリ働いている女性たちである。
同じ席になると居心地のすごく悪そうな顔をするのだが、それは自分たちの空虚な日々の生活を見透かされるような気分になるからであろう。
同じ会場にSランAラン大卒の女子と、自称モデルと、アホな女子大生などが混ざっており、段々と酔っていく。
マンションは100平米以上はあり、3LDKなのか4LDKなのかわからなかったが、広いリビングに人が集まっていて、別の部屋もあった。
参加者たちをよく観察していると、酔った女子大生が半グレっぽいみための男と廊下の奥の方に2人で消えていくのを見た。
しばらくして私がたまたまトイレに行って済ませて廊下を歩いているとドアが1つちょっとだけ空いていて、中からうっすら声が聞こえてくるのでなんだろう?と思って覗いてみると、
ベッドで半グレ男が女子大生にベッドで覆いかぶさって、思いっきりやっていた。
ドアをちゃんと閉めてなかったし鍵も当然閉めてなかったのだが、それにしても普通に他人がやっているのを見るのは初めてであった。
その女子大生に性的同意があったのか、酔った状態で無理やりだったのかはわからないが、とにかくやっていた。
「せめて会が終わってからとか、他の場所でやれよ…せめて鍵閉めろよ」
と思ったのだが、その女子大生もパリピ的な雰囲気の女子だったし、同意があってやっているのかないのかもわからなかったので、とりあえず自分はリビングに戻り、また元いた場所に戻ってお酒と食事を続けることにした。
男性側も非常に多種多様で、McKinseyのエリートから外銀、商社から若手経営者、何やっているかわからない男、見た目半グレ系までが混ざっており、これまでなるべく平和な会ばかりを選んで行っていた自分にとっては久々の危ない連中が混ざっている会だなと思った。
さて、夜も耽ってきて23時くらいになると、気づいたらその半グレと女子大生も会場に戻ってきており、何もなかったかのような顔で酒を飲んでいる。
女子大生はややメイクが乱れている程度で、髪も元通りのようで、ここにいる誰一人として何が起きていたかを見破った人はいなかったとおもう。
女子大生もそこに戻っているということは、同意があったのだろうか。
こういうパーティは、20時頃から人が集まり始め、22時くらいにピークを迎え、23時〜となると帰る人も出てきて気づいたら人が減っていたりもする。
だいたい0時くらいになると
「クラブでも行こうぜ」
的な流れがあって、六本木とかのクラブ(いわゆるナンパの箱)に移動したりするのが定番であった。
コロナ後からはクラブに行くというのは減ったと聞く。
コカイン大麻マンション
23時すぎになってきて人がやや減ってきたあたりで、半グレたちとも話していると、
「俺の先輩のところでもパーティしてるらしくて、一緒にいかね?」
などと言ってきて、5−6人で行こうと誘ってくる。
その横のいたエリサラ外銀が
「〜〜先輩?ああ、いいねいこう」
みたいなことを言うし、このTHE ROPPONGI TOKYOの会場ももういいかな、帰ろうかなと思っていたタイミングだったので、軽い気持ちで
「いいよ、行こう」
などと言った。
歩いていけなくもない距離であったがタクシーに乗り、麻布エリアのある建物に到着した。
見た目はマンションというよりはオフィスビルであり、たわまんではない。
ちょっと怪しいなと思いながらも、エレベーターに乗り、10Fで降りる。
入口はなんともない本当にただの鉄の扉であったが、外に監視カメラがあったのは気になった。
ピンポンを押してしばらくすると、中から入れ墨だらけの男が上半身裸で出てきて、
「こいつら誰？
」
と聞いてくる。
半グレは
「ああ、パーティ一緒にしてた友達です!いいっすか?」
などといって、中に入った。
中は薄暗く、すごく大きな音で音楽が鳴っている。
中に入ると、中は2階建てになっており、いくつかの部屋があるが、多くはつながっていて巨大な2LDKのようになっている。
そして、何やら煙たい感じが鼻と目に感じる。
ああ、これはマリファナの匂いだなと理解する。
マリファナの匂いだとわかるのは、アメリカ旅行に行ったときに、マリファナをやっているやつになんどか出くわしたことがあるので、同じだと理解できたのであった。
右奥の薄暗い部屋で、中はうっすらピンク色のライトの間接照明。
何故かビキニのギャルと、上裸で入れ墨だらけの男がいちゃついている。
廊下を歩くと足に何か当たり、なんだろう？
と足元を見ると、注射器が落ちていた。
注射器で摂取する薬物といえば覚醒剤であり、覚醒剤を服用して性行為を行うと、極度の快感が得られるというが、副作用も非常に大きい。
「うわ、やばいとこ来たな」
と思いながらも、まあこの時点で逃げ出しても何されるかわからないし、早めに帰ろう、と思いながら中を進む。
階段を登ると、ドアがあいている部屋があり、今度はモデルのようなキャバ嬢のような細い女性と、また入れ墨が入った男がやっていた。
狂ったように声を出していたから、あれは覚醒剤でもやっていたのだろうか。
女性は上半身だけビキニで、下は履いていなかった。
というか、なぜ女性たちがみなビキニなのかは謎であったが、男性たちも上半身裸であった。
進むと今度は広いベランダがあり、今度は外になんにんかが入れるジャグジーがあり、また水着のギャルと、半グレ入れ墨がいる。
このジャグジーに入って遊ぶために水着でいたのだろうと理解した。
パーティで知り合った半グレは、半グレの先輩らしき40代らしい男性に
「〜〜さん!こんばんは!ちょっと友達連れてきちゃいました!」
などといって挨拶をしていたが、まあ普通の人間であることを相手も理解してか、その半グレ先輩は
「おう」
くらいしか言わなかった。
そこで酒を出してくれると言うのでテーブルに座ったのだが、半グレ先輩はテーブルには来ないでジャグジーに入り電話に出て流暢な英語で電話をし始めた。
ゆな先生は英語はまあまあできる方(大学卒業時でTOEIC900点以上はあった)だったので少し声が遠いが何を話しているが聞き取れはする。
半グレはどうもシンガポールと電話をしているようで、何かの投資の件と、香港から持ってくる荷物の件がどうのという話をしている。
見た目は明らかに土建屋でもやっているような典型的半グレ、大きなガタイとジャガイモのような顔の半グレなのだが、その英語の流暢さには強烈な違和感を感じた。
「そこにある酒のんでいいから」
などと言ってワインとかウイスキーが置いてあるテーブルを後輩に指差して再び英語での通話に戻った。
後輩は慣れた様子で棚からグラスを取り出し、シャンパンを注いでくれた。
銘柄は当時の私は知らなかったが、グラスは妙に汚れており、テーブルの上には吸い殻や空のペットボトル、誰のものかわからないスマートフォンが散乱していた。
注がれたシャンパンは、珍しかったのであとで名前を調べたが、バロン・ド・ロスチャイルドという、ロスチャイルド家の末裔が経営している高級シャンパンで、市川海老蔵の結婚式で出されたものであった。
麻布十番で半グレに灰皿テキーラをやってぶん殴られた海老蔵のシャンパンというのがまたいろいろと考えさせてくる。
1本8000円くらい
THE ROPPONGI TOKYOのパーティでは、安いワインでも一応はグラスが並べられ、オードブルが置かれ、「ちゃんとしたパーティ」の体裁が保たれていた。
このコカインマンションにも金はあるし高い酒もある。
広い部屋もジャグジーもある。
モデルのような女もいる。
ただ、やはり何か危ない雰囲気が漂っていた。
白い粉
しばらくテーブルで酒を飲みながら、連れてきた男たちと話していると、別の部屋から若い男が小さな皿を持ってきた。
皿の上には白い粉があり、横には丸めた紙幣のような紙のようなものが置かれていた。
何の説明もなく
「やる？
」
くらいの軽い調子で聞かれた。
私はすぐに断った。
その場にいたエリサラ外銀の男も断るのかと思ったら、
「あした早いから少しだけ」
などと言って笑ってどこかへ消えていった。
あしたが早いなら普通はやらないだろうと思ったが、彼は特に緊張する様子もなく、まるで誰かからタバコを一本もらうような態度であった。
誰もが知っている外銀マンがやるのかよ、と思いながらも、そこで初めて、この場所に連れてこられた全員、私と同じような何も知らない普通の客ではないことに気づいたのである。
そう、皆がおかしいのではなく、何もやらないゆな先生がおかしいのである。
THE ROPPONGI TOKYOでワインを飲み、仕事や恋愛の話をしていた男が、こちらでは当たり前のように違法薬物を目の前にしている。
もしかするとエリサラみたいな外銀マンもいぜんにもここへ来たことがあり、半グレたちとも最初から知り合いだったのかもしれない。
「先輩のところでもパーティしてる」という言葉から、私は勝手に、似たようなホームパーティを想像していた。
しかし、彼らの言うパーティとは、私の考えるパーティとは全く違うものだった。
違法薬物というのは自分の生活に近い場所にあるんだなあと今となっては恐ろしく感じる。
この水着ギャルたちは好き好んでここに来ているのか、それとも仕方なくなのか、騙されたのか、どういう経緯でここにきてるのかはよくわからなかった。
部屋の奥
海老蔵の泡を一口だけ飲み、帰る理由を考えていると、テーブルに置かれたスマートフォンの一台が鳴った。
後輩の男がそれを取り、
「はい、ただいま確認します」
と、突然丁寧な口調で話し始めた。
先ほどまで「マジっすか」「やばいっすね」などと言っていた人間と同一人物とは思えない声だった。
電話を切ると、男は隣の部屋に移動した。
ドアが完全には閉まらなかったので、中が少し見えた。
部屋には机がいくつか並び、その上に大量の携帯電話とノートパソコンが置かれていた。
壁には人の名前らしきものや金額、電話番号が書かれた紙が貼ってあって、「目標必達」と筆の字が書いてあったのを覚えている。
このシャンパンパーティとの違和感が凄まじい。
何のための部屋なのかわからなかったが、なんとなくまともな商売の部屋ではなさそうというのは理解できた。
当時はまだ闇バイト強盗とかはなかったがオレオレ詐欺とか怪しい投資詐欺とかはいっぱいあった。
あの部屋が投資なのか、詐欺なのか、違法な賭博なのかはわからないし、ジャグジーで英語を話している入れ墨男と、この携帯電話とPCの山が関係があるのかもわからないし、それぞれの名前すらもわからない。
同じ組織の人間なのかどうかすらわからなかった。
帰るタイミング
ベランダに戻るど、ジャグジーに浸かった先輩半グレは、電話で「レートがどうの」とか「あいつがいなくなった」といった内容を、まるで外資系金融の幹部のような流暢なビジネス英語で話し続けていて、こちらには一瞥もしなかった。
見た目はド派手な刺青とジャイアンのような体格だが、頭脳は完全に国際的な金融マンのようで、裏社会も脳筋とインテリのハイブリッドで動いてるんだなあと実感した。
こいつももともとはエリートだったのかもしれない。
電話を切った後、先輩は日本語で誰かに指示を出し始めた。
そこで初めて、日本語のほうの語彙が耳に入ってきた。
名簿がどうとか、口座がどうとか、飛んだやつがどうとか、そういう話である。
私はその方面に詳しいわけではないので、具体的に何をやっているのかまでは理解できなかった。
ただ、聞こえてくる単語の組み合わせから、これが投資の話の何かなんだろうなというのだけはわかる。
それにしても一番ぞっとしたのは、その半グレ先輩の英語が本当に流暢だったことである。
顔はジャガイモで、ガタイは土建屋で、上半身は裸で入れ墨だらけなのに、電話口では明らかに教育を受けた人間の英語を話す。
どこかで留学でもしていたのか、それとも必要に迫られて身につけたのか。
我々は反社や半グレを「馬鹿がやるもの」だと思いたがるが、実際にその世界の上のほうにいる人間は、単純に優秀なのである。
優秀な人間が、たまたま非合法な側でレバレッジをかけている。
それだけの話だった。
この構図に気づいたとき、はじめて本気で帰りたくなった。
バカ相手ならまだしも、インテリ半グレ相手は色々とめんどくさそうである。
時計を見ると1時半を回っていた。
一緒に来た外銀エリサラは、いつのまにか女の子と一緒に消えていた。
声をかけてきた半グレの若い男は、先輩のところで機嫌をとるのに忙しそうだった。
このまま朝までいると、たぶん何か引き返せないことが一つは起きる。
やるかやらないかしぶとく聞かれるか、写真を撮られるか、誰かと連絡先を交換して、この部屋の呼べる人のリストに載るか。
帰ることにした。
トイレに行くふりをして玄関に向かった。
玄関の前には、来たときの入れ墨の男が座っていて、こちらを見た。
「帰るの?」
「はい、あしたどうしても朝早くて」
嘘ではあったが、この夜で二度目の同じ嘘である。
止められるかと思ったが、男は
「ふーん」
とだけ言ってドアを開けてくれた。
「あ、なんかみた?」
「いや、何もみてないです」
「そうだよね」
廊下に出た瞬間、音楽が聞こえなくなって静かになった。
ドアが閉まると、音楽はほとんど聞こえなくなる。
あのビルの外を歩いている人は、10階で何が起きているかを絶対に知らない。
エレベーターを降りて外に出ると、麻布の路地は嘘みたいに普通の夜だった。
コンビニの明かりがついていて、酔ったサラリーマンが電話をしながら歩いている。
タクシーを拾って、自分の家の場所を言った。
誰もタク代はくれなかったが、良いのだ。
窓の外を六本木が流れていく間、ずっと、あのビルの見た目を思い出していた。
いつか何かおきたときのためにビルの場所をグーグル Mapでピン留めしておいた。
絶対に周りからみても半グレの巣窟には見えない、半グレマンション。
まだあそこで同じことをやっているのだろうか。
その後のこと
後日、一緒に行った外銀エリサラから連絡があって、
「この前のあそこ、またやるらしいけど行く?」
と誘われた。
行かなかった。
その後ももう一度誘われたが、なんどか断っていると、誘われなくなる。
その外銀エリサラが今どうしているかは知らないし、本名も聞かなかったからどうしているか知りようがない。
部屋の奥に連れていかれた女子大生も、誰一人として追跡していないし、あの半グレマンションが今どうなっているかも全くわからない。
港区のああいう場所は、人がすごい速度で入れ替わるので、半年会わないと存在ごと忘れる。
ただ、あの日からなんねんかして、一度だけテレビのニュースで「あ、こいつ」と思ったことがあった。
容疑は意外なことに強制わいせつだった。
道端で女の胸を突然揉んだらしい。
薬をやりすぎて頭がおかしくなったのだろうか。
境界線
ヤマトリノのニュースに話を戻す。
ネットでは、彼氏がいたことに腹を立てた知人が売っただの、キャバ嬢だからだの、いろいろ言われている。
逮捕されたのだから法的な責任は当然あるし、そこを擁護するつもりはない。
ただ、私が言いたいのはそこではない。
私が言いたいのは、あの日の私と、あの部屋十回断って十一回目に「やる?」と聞かれた誰かとの間に、たいした差はなかったということである。
私は反社が嫌いだったからおじさん主催のパーティを避けていたし、たまたまその日はあした早いと嘘をついて帰った。
ただそれだけの話で、私は品行方正だったわけでも、危機察知能力が高かったわけでもない。
たわまんのパーティで泡を飲んでいた場所と、注射器が落ちている部屋との距離は、タクシーで10分もなかった。
歩いていけたと思う。
しかも、「先輩んとこでもパーティやってるらしいよ」という一言でつながっていて、気軽なものであった。
XやLINEで高額バイトの募集に手を伸ばすのと、構造はまったく同じである。
入口はいつも、とんでもなく軽い。
だからこそ、薬物のニュースとか半グレ絡みのニュースをみて
「怖いね」
「遠い世界だね」
と言っている人たちに、私はこう思っている。
遠くない。
歩いて行ける距離にある。
一歩道を間違うどころか、気づいたらその罠にかかっている。
ちなみに、その半グレマンションであるが、ジャグジーは露天であるので、衛星写真でも見ることが出来る。
ピン留めした場所を改めてみてみると、まだグーグル 衛星写真ではジャグジーは確認できた。
まだやってるのだろうか。
それとも、もう誰もいなくて普通の人が住んでいるのだろうか。
当時はシンガポールだったかもしれないが、きっと今はドバイとかカンボジアとか、ミャンマーなんかに展開して、半グレももっともっと国際化してるんだろうと思う。
ヤマトリノ事件も、組織犯罪の捜査のごくいちぶでしかなく、本丸は別の半グレとトクリュウなのだろう。
港区界隈の関係者ならこの記事の場所も「あ、あそこだな」とわかるかもしれないけど、私の身の安全を守るためにも、ビルの実名は出さないでほしい。
きょうは公開を悩んだが、もう時間も経過したし大丈夫だろうと思って公開した。
普段と違う記事となったが、ぜひまた次の記事にも期待されたい。
ゆな先生より
コメント
メンバーシップ
ゆな先生経済日記
ゆな先生日記　基本プラン
ゆな先生
億り人の投資家かつしがない労働者です
さいきんの記事を見る
ヘルプ /
利用規約
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。